the first law of reflection states that  the angle between the incident ray and  the normal is equal to the angle between  the reflected ray and the normal let's  consider a plane mirror like this and  this ray is incident on the mirror the  normal is this dotted line which is at a  right angle to the mirror or the surface  this ray is incident at an angle i from  the normal like this  and let this be the reflected ray which  is formed at an angle r from the normal  as per the first law angle i will always  be equal to angle r if you increase the  measure of angle i then angle r will  also increase the second law states that  the incident ray the normal and the  reflected ray are all in the same plane  diagrammatically it will look like this  they will all lie on the same plane like  this now can you tell me if the incident  and reflected race always lie on the  same side of the normal  [Music]